this episode of true news is sponsored
by the mobile game called golf clash now
last week we didn't do sponsored video
we didn't put any ads in the video it
didn't feel right but like anyone in
order to continue we do need to keep the
lights on we do need support and thanks
the golf clash were back again and also
we're going to use a portion of the
money we get from the sponsorship to
support the movements going on right now
and you can't to the donation link will
be in the description below so let's
tell you a little bit about golf clash
because in the time that we've been
apart both of us thought how good can a
golf game actually be but it turns out
really pretty honestly you will enjoy
this if you play with your mates I
promise you you will enjoy yeah you you
versus me has actually been summer most
fun that I've had and I get on a game
with someone else
yeah and there are a lot of games there
gets annoying when you gotta be honest
but it's sort of it's annoying because
you get that feeling like when you're
playing real golf where you're like yeah
so this is better than real golf because
there's just no walk and involved
yeah perfect for him in that case and
that exact reason you can see why it is
the biggest sports game in the US and
for you I don't know if L wanted me to
say this but it just remind me of the
Nintendo Wii games used I use addictive
to the golf game on there yeah I get
that it's quite like that but it's like
on your mobile easier better
you've gotta anticipate the roll down
the hill and you've got to try and use
the wind yeah and all you get your
little what is it wedge wedges Laver I'm
getting in the way honestly I'm really
enjoying not only that but he's kind of
person person person is good but then
what I love is afterwards you can go
back and go are personalized these Cubs
a little bit upgrade them you get these
crazy names for them that sort of thing
I found out the other day that actually
hopefuls as well you can some of the
golf balls for like footballs
right okay yeah you need to make that
clear but you get footballs as well
footballs it just say here there are new
balls released every week with powerful
spin power and wind resistance that's
the other thing was there's loads great
courses so I can be around the world in
LA or I can be in loads different weird
places favorite golfer probably Rory
McIlroy Hugh shoot over govern you've
really found me there that was a real
code book yeah it shows Peterson's a
quality player he's never been the same
since he lost his hand we don't rehearse
this just hide it on so this genuinely
is a great game the link to play is in
the description below its freedom player
yep which is awesome yeah it is yeah
yeah I'll just open shot because it
seems to it seems premium she's not yeah
premi and the supporters show in the
lockdown so big shut up for them once
again yeah make sure you go get on the
fields get on the greens yeah get your
little you know get over their rank up
start competing against your friends and
you could become friends like we are and
know all the true news welcome back the
true news [__] Paul has been arrested
we got him guys we got the guy that did
the serious thing the guy who was at the
place where the thing happened yeah cuz
that's [__] yeah it's not important
I mean I just wanted to get their
attention so that now we can feed you
the important the real stuff all four
police officers are now facing charges
to do with the murder of George
Floyd which is good news it is sad news
obviously it's it's obviously sad what
happened we covered it in depth last
week but at least they've upgraded the
main charge of Derek shavon to
second-degree murder from third which is
what we said last week and the other
office is now involved as well they
basically charged with aiding and
abetting second-degree murder which
they're [__] with me this is the
easiest open-and-shut case ever as
pleased as some of us are about this it
can't be seen as a victory because you
have to look at what it took to get
justice what should be handed out anyone
if this wasn't filmed Derek's oven would
have labeled ours resisting arrest the
guy would probably be on number 19 of
his complaints of police brutality if
anyone reported if we're lucky enough to
get it reported him and all is made to
be planned on the post corvid holidays
George Freud's family would be
devastated and would never get any hint
of justice they'd have no hope
whatsoever and even though it was filmed
it still took 10 days of peaceful
protests riots do you have to move
heaven and earth just to get these
police in front of a judge let alone
sentence we don't know what's gonna
happen next so this is just the start
it's not the end of anything this
another person I feel sorry for in this
is the young girl who filmed it who
is a now going through therapy because
she's seen someone die in front of her
at the hands of a police officer imagine
trying to trust society after you've
seen that happen trying to feel safe
when you think the people are supposed
to keep you safe are actually killing
you and then on top of that you have
people harassing you for doing the right
thing but sadly what people are saying
is why didn't you interject because she
didn't feel safe around police services
year old girl witnessing for police
officers kill what was a mountain of a
man in Floyd he was not a small my guy
was a 17 year old girl gonna do at this
point what you gonna call the police
they are the book and police don't worry
there's already officers on the scene
yeah I know we're getting lots of
problems me yeah could you send some
good one yeah let's take a look at some
of the protests and some what people
have said about that yeah this is the
LAPD Chief Michael Moore we didn't have
protests last night we had criminal acts
his death is on their hands as much as
it is those officers and that is a
strong statement we must turn a corner
from the rules from people who were who
are involved in violence he's a great
speaker yeah great let me I plugged this
with today LAPD chief pages you've gotta
say right his logic is arable is after
the fact after those police officers
murdered that man in cold blood
yeah people were rioting right yes some
of them were looting and all that
rubbish right point is he is now saying
that that death is on their hands
because they did appropriately after the
death occurred back to the future type
logic there's a lot of white people here
I feel are doing mental gymnastics to
try and justify what their view is now
instead of going yeah I think we got
this one wrong just make you wonder why
a chief of police would not want the
blame labeled but the fee of the police
nice funny really yeah wonder why you
would do the strange isn't it probably
the guy's just a [__] [__] when
the police in Grand Theft Auto are
better at policing than the police in
real life then you know you have any
even on one star I'm aware of it you
know this footage of the police officers
work during the gun shoot oh good [__]
just leave them yeah let them get on
with it you see smart one less for us to
worry about I'm all right or ten not
really why you getting
yeah they're trying to flag them down
we're trying to flag down the cops just
a context this is a family being filmed
here who owned a store begging for the
police's help to come and protect the
business that they owned from looters so
this in Kamiya help us help us they're
literally waving the police over there's
the first clue right that you're not a
looter it's that the looter is welcoming
you as a policeman to come help well I'm
not a criminal yeah can we just get that
out there but if I was I probably
wouldn't try and draw as much attention
as humanly possible I've gotten uh yeah
I wouldn't be doing that it just goes to
show you perhaps overwhelmed the police
department is right now the news they
stop making excuses for why the police
appeal straight posture yeah it's called
free associating it's what people on the
news do when they just watch images of
things and they try and make up a
narrative as it go so you go are those
pork police so overwhelmed they're run
rugged right no they've completely
missed them all eight of them are
heading in exactly the same direction
they must need every person they can get
in three days of surreal moments on TV
this is one of the most surreal moments
we've seen what is underway right now in
Van Nuys all right so here come the
police officers to help these community
members here they come here they come at
top speed by the way this guy is a horse
stepping towards the blue let me just
okay I'm on the way it's chief Wiggum
basically this is chief Lee yeah it was
looks like we got ourselves an
old-fashioned car chase
no they're fine they're good gosh
they're run the looters so people
looting are now running away on camera
there goes a policeman they can't
believe their luck tiller yeah [__] me
they think they're the little yes
they're the shop owners I'll see you
later
this guy's got away the poor woman with
a home that's why I love about the
police swift action there they go
straight in boom boom arrested don't
worry guys the bad guys are finally
restrained we've got them all it's the
it was the black guy it was the bad guys
dude it's cool don't worry about it it's
clear the blacks yep I love this guy
right it's chief Wickham this guy's
sprinted in he's you just stand down for
a sec you need to calm down
this guy's wheezing as he's coming over
to this woman and going you need to calm
down
wanting directly out to point people
then he goes you need to point them out
those guys and not the looters which
one's the ones I'm pointing at no point
the ones you're a rooster these guys are
playing a game of [__] charades while
they're doing it nut movie movie yes a
movie yeah TV you're with TV we get it
okay book no no the looters okay this
one must be so frustrated Urals homework
yeah one word looters good okay we've
got them now tell me the direction no
it's protecting this door now we're
laughing but imagine the fear in these
store owners Minds when police come
running toward you don't wanna come
across as in sunset because I'm laughing
at the sheer incompetence of the clowns
who are in office although uniforms oh
this is amazingly bad and surely these
guys got released after this one this is
just [__] her run you'd hope so I
think what most people don't realize is
if you have a gun pointed at you you're
one click away from dead you should be
the most frightening moment of your life
you're already disoriented you're
already upset because your store has
just been looted and then
someone comes in and points at you yeah
imagine that it's unbelievable that
they're going through this people in the
scenario going why can't the people who
are talking to the police calm down the
people are talking the police don't have
training in this each one of these
policemen is trained to do this job do
they just forget their training the
second thing I'd love to see what kind
of trainer because when I watch silence
or the love yeah she got well true
absolutely but it turns out that that
was just a movie whereas police academy
documentary this is the NYPD radio so
it's basically the coppers saying don't
arrest them whoever they are just shoot
those [__] there's a lot of
this I've gotta warn you it's not it's
not good vibes yeah not only that it's
not only that them saying it is then
them going don't say yeah not in public
mate yeah that's even worse we wanted to
put this in because it was just such a
sad story that came out from all of this
this fella called David McAtee a
Louisville barbecue chef who was known
for serving cops free meals could you
get any more supportive of them than
that he was shot and killed by the
police he was unarmed not only where the
officers body comes off but they also
left his body on the street for 12 hours
how can they turn body comes off
everyone should be always always on
always accountable everything should be
document not only we've you seen body
cams off we've seen name tags removed
we've seen any insignia for the police
removed as well so that you can't
identify the people who do exactly
this is the crazy bit unbelievable I
mean that what you just seen was two
police officers in a crowd that weren't
trying to smash the concept yes they
were throwing the odd thing on top of
the car but they weren't good it caused
any serious damage or harm to the
officers or cause they put their foot
down and they drive as fast as they want
into a crowd of people kill them don't
kill them they don't give a [__] for all
the people who thought a few bad apples
you know occasionally warned not one or
two bad police officers will do
something [__] that's just part of it
how many examples we have seen in the
last week of psychopaths with barges is
astounding no regard for human life
treating people like vermin like people
they can just shoot kill they don't give
a [__] I have a badge I can do what I
like that is the attitude of so many
police officers in America you know I
really hope that the English police look
at this and go we're gonna be different
because if these pro it has become more
and more common I hope we can look at
the English policing for thank God you
know we've got some sensible ones who
aren't [__] crazy bastards we've seen
a mixture of mentally unstable people
racist people like people who just want
to go into the crowd of protesters and
start some [__] there's a Venn diagram
mentally unstable people and racists
they tend to cross over and what we're
also finding is well it doesn't work out
too well for them
the sky's as good as dead right now
we don't know if he is there but we
don't know they did hit him inhabit the
skateboard and stone them [__] me like
if you are protesting the murder of
George Floyd even if a crazy person
comes over to you and starts saying some
crazy [__] racist [__] you have to
maintain that moral high ground to be
able to have your point hood and to be
able to keep people from deterring away
from what your messages and by doing
things like this
they gave the ability over to the LAPD
police chief to go oh well it's just as
bad as them it's just as much they felt
they need stop this for younger even
some of them fight with the police but
it's when other citizens get brought
into it and then they get [__] off
you're ruining your own argument even
though you probably said some really
fucked-up [__] here's the issue you
can't say that violence defines that
movement in that way because it doesn't
they're their core message is a good
message and it seems like it's a small
percentage of violent people getting
involved to promote riots and all of
that but the problem is the worst [__]
always is the bit that gets shown like
what we're doing right now
I'm sure there's good police officers
who support you know black lives matter
who are all about the barge in what it
really means which is protecting to
serve the community but there's just so
many bad examples of those people that
we can't not acknowledge him and the
same goes for the [__] who are on
the other side as well yeah I heard a
good analogy the other day you don't go
down to a cancer fundraiser and walk in
and go all illnesses matter it's not the
time to do that you're not going to go
should we debate if the cancer is
actually deadly you just walk in and you
say this is a good cause and I stand by
that and this is similar there are
people going down to a black lives
matter protest and going see I think
white people are also suffering is not
the time for it no one gives a [__]
about your other mess at all so usually
those people bankís yes say it with us
at home they're wankers yeah this was
sad this is a child who got caught in
Tigges what do you think about that
there's many things wrong with this you
know the police shouldn't be [__]
throwing tear gas around like it's party
poppers which they are you know what
could happen as a parent if you're going
through this kind of protest if you
can't get a child
you've got like tough look after your
child is your number one job in this
[__] world if what you want to do in
your day-to-day life puts that child at
risk in any way and you go well you know
you just go you know I've got to have a
voice and I'm sorry but like stay at
home you know I mean do a bit from home
you can do stuff from home I just think
that you shouldn't be bringing a kid to
anyway that could get violent the next
clip was taken the day after Donald
Trump speech will get the whip but he
sort of was like oh yeah I'm all for
peaceful protesters but you know violent
people will be dealt with
you be the judge of what he's told the
police officers as you can see here a
peaceful family Street it's idyllic
because yeah yeah this looks beautiful
yeah this looks like if I lived in one
of these houses in America regardless of
location I'd be thrilled
let's go nothing's burning down me I'm
just looking at my front door yeah I'm
literally standing on my own property
really Abadi didn't buy the curve here
on my doorstep yeah I look out my
[__] door no then on the front door
Graham we just get ready to head out
just got my caught on yeah just get my
comb we're heading down to one of the
local restaurants we're going to Walmart
and do a little bit lovely yeah
I often think the first thing that I
would do when trying to convince people
that were on their side and that this is
for the best for them is to make really
loud noises and and shoot tool in their
direction I never think hey you should
we should go over there and just explain
what's going on here because this must
look really scary actually
hundreds of us walking down the street
in some sort of formation trying to tell
people to go if it's something this is
the thing Trump can say all he wants but
the clear message internally to the
police is brute force I don't care if
they're peaceful not peaceful get rid of
them and that is clear as day these
people are allegedly out past curfew and
that's why the police are opening their
car doors and saying right you better
get home or whatever again here first
they have curfew so just a little hey
guys sorry scurf you now I know this
unusual but everyone just needs to head
back to their house nothing to worry
about in a very tense day for everyone
let's just go home bearing in mind we've
had a lot of the similar sort of stuff
with corvid 19 in lockdown and that all
seemed to be quite smooth yeah all right
well yeah we're all getting used to it's
a bit strange isn't it yeah no they're
they took a different approach you can
actually see the panic on these guys
faces immediately in the car even though
I mean they're surrounded by a SWAT to
imagine how much just driving yeah
exactly and a whole team is converging
on their car imagine that I'm able to
see the panic on a guy's face on a small
part of a television screen that's
already been shrunk down which then been
filmed on a mobile phone and we can see
how panicked that guy is she's not
refusing to cut out the tumor she's just
freaking freaking out she's scared
because they're tasing who know they're
tasing them both she's being tased there
he gets her off yeah he's trying to pull
the the things out of her and then he's
getting tased
I mean this is just not necessary yeah
there's been so many examples of people
just being attacked by police in the
last week not a guy who's in the middle
of committing a crime and the end of
fighting with a cop I'm not talking
about that I'm talking about people
getting attacked
unarmed no reason for it peaceful
protesters people are bystanders yeah
getting tased
I'll probably never look at police the
same way again and that's that's a shame
because there are many good people out
there who are police officers and I know
a few I thought like many did us a few
bad apples here is [__] in the last
week the amount of videos we've seen
where people are just cycles with barges
you can't
wiped from your memory you can no longer
think it's bad apples you go look at the
tree
having said that Brian there are some
lovely people out there who are doing
brilliant white fantasy we all at one
point or another have wanted to dress up
as Batman am i right I've done it before
exactly yeah not in the bedroom you
[__] freak no no okay
this guy took someone else's serious
cause and trivialize it by dressing as a
DC comic character with all the small
them but the way he's walking over this
really does look reminiscent of the
final scene yeah Rhys the only things
taken away from Izzy's walking on the
grass there's no grass it looks so real
it does look real they yeah sadly this
[__] thinks it's time to play out his
fantasy so basically well I've only seen
the spot okay I don't give a [__] who
the [__] you think you are dressing as
Batman and going along to someone else's
protest even though Batman's suit is
black does not mean you're sporting the
cause he's using someone else's cause to
play out his own DC comic fantasy
because he's a sick [__] he's a white
guy who thinks this is a good time for
me to dress up as Batman know it's a
good time for you to go out hold up a
placard it's not [__] off emerged him
this is what I keep thinking he doesn't
live in the bucket he lives in a regular
home this man is not walked out of Wayne
Manor chances are someone's had to help
him get into that yeah and I can just
imagine one mom does it look right do we
need any more thought I'd make and he's
like right okay and he has one last look
at himself in the mirror before he shuts
the door locks the door yeah and he's
off and he's what he's more Pettersen
he's not showing up in the Batmobile
so that way strange yeah he probably got
a new brother at what point do you
realize bro you're ridiculous even when
I was five and I dressed up as Batman
had stepped out the front door of my
house I thought do I look silly
there's a lot of people getting involved
in protests or getting involved in the
black lives matter movement because of
how it can benefit them yeah there are
some people who just want to be pictured
they want to have the clout or look a
certain way on their Instagram or speak
about it in a certain way online because
it makes them look better yeah they've
been found out a lot of cons but some
some people
you can work it out for yourself here we
go here's the other angle of what we
showed you earlier this is so [__] up
yeah he I mean he really could have
killed someone they're so lucky that
someone didn't fall under the car oh my
god have you seen that yeah it's just
troubled by a foot police horse I mean I
mean that is just you are ones being
violent yeah
genuinely I feel like the police leant
over to the other guy and went watch
this I mean just they've had all of
these toys yeah and they've been like in
the locker room just call me look kicks
off to use this I tell you and now it's
all happened as I'd finally the day has
come
oh yes some of these people join the
police years ago to play policeman what
is the rational excuse for before
needing to do that the cars pretty heavy
we need to get off some weight here yeah
that kind of stuff yes what's in the
canister just water yeah just get rid of
it get rid of it that's weighing us down
yeah exactly yeah I do feel like some of
these policemen see wearing the uniform
in the same way as that man saw you
wearing that no janata is right is I get
it on some level when I used to clean a
butcher shop when I was cleaning the
blood off of the walls in the freezer I
didn't get a lot of self-esteem I think
that in some ways as long as I felt that
it works the opposite way when you're a
police officer right they get such an
identity of having that uniform on they
get such a buzz off of it and they feel
above some people and both other people
they feel like um you know I've got I've
got authority over you I could I could
do I could arrest you if I want right
now just like that just make up a reason
cuz they're good
I can I can arrest you for resisting
arrest a genuine thing that happened in
this past week you're resisting arrest
what are you arresting me for for
resisting the arrest what were you
arrested before in the first place
resisting arrest original yes yeah is
mental and power can be a bit over drug
these guys are getting really carried
away it's just there needs to be major
reform the whole entire police in
America especially they need to come out
and go look we've got this wrong in
order to get back any credibility in
order to get anything back from the
people any respect again you need to
hold your hands up as a complete
organization ago we [__] up so we know
we have we've got this wrong we want to
be better we want to work with the
people to be better and we want to meet
the people and actually be a community
because right now this is so divided and
a lot of this does fall on Trump to make
happen and I think he rules with fear
and not with love and that's the problem
here so we're not going to get that kind
of unity again somehow these police
forgot that they are the people
literally putting on a uniform it makes
you feel like you're not a normal person
and that's part of the problem yeah
people who are destroying things if you
really feel like you have to take an
opportunity like if you're gonna be an
opportunistic something is wrong with
you
if you cannot stand up and fight the
good fight and you want to be a cheater
and go ahead and take what we're trying
to do something is wrong with you
because what we're trying to do is stand
up for the basic right of humanity and
that's what we're trying to do and we're
trying to do in a peaceful way that's a
powerful point and I think people are
right to sort of hover Gordon Lewis
because they're taking away from the
overall message from the message from
people like this people who care for
years and he's frustrated but to go
along with that let's not forget there's
40 million people in America who are
unemployed who have been starving for
months and who haven't got [__] if
they're giving in to those urges and not
supporting the greater message it's
wrong but I understand it we found a
descendant of Robin Hood it turns out
it's a [__] in a t-shirt yeah it's I
mean when are we going to hear the
voices of white people when will white
people be heard in this world enough for
us look exactly yes love it love it so
hard it's difficult we've been saying it
as white people on podcasts for years
when will we be heard you know when will
our votes matter when can we just walk
out in public and not worry about the
police
[Music]
I think he took a little so he shot at
that guy from feet away the force on a
bow and arrow is incredible [__]
deadly this is this is badass a bullet
and in the crowd take charge and they
beat the [__] out of them yeah and
somehow we got out alive you see him lie
about what happened later on the
interview yeah the little prick I never
want to see someone beaten to a pulp but
I think when you go into that sort of
environment and you do that there's
almost no other course of action I don't
really believe in karma but in this
circumstance you can call it what you
want yeah he got his ass kicked then he
was asking for it how did you get hurt
on your forehead because I got my window
cops did somebody hit you with some yes
two black african-americans they beat me
through my open window that I yelled out
all lives matter you left out the bit
with the bone arrow in your hand that's
the main issue here technically what
this man is saying is correct but he's
leaving out the key details and he was
pointing a lethal weapon at the end of
people yeah the one that he's come on
for the coil afterwards as well yeah
what kind of crazy bus that is this guy
must have a YouTube channel we're giving
racists a post much press conference
here like I don't quite understand
what's going on let's look at some of
the peaceful protests this is in Denver
here people laying on their front it's a
very powerful image people mimicking
basically aware that George Floyd was
put down to good way of commemorating
there's a real powerful message
especially around these buildings with
the American flag and stuff this is in
the UK Trafalgar Square
watching this protest I'm 100% behind it
and I think that people are doing it for
the right reasons but it also makes you
realize just how far we've come in the
lockdown and where it is now because at
the star the idea of people protesting
was laughter they were viewed as psychos
and these are people who all right the
you know mainstream media laughed at
them and said all the 5j protesters but
many of them were protesting the
depression that lockdown was causing the
fact that kids were missing months of
school that people weren't able to go to
the funerals of their dead relatives
that serious stuff and people who were
losing businesses people their
livelihood was going under they were
crying out for help and they were told
no it doesn't matter because if we all
mix with each other
grandmas will die so we all at respect
that and we all did respect that
Lawrence wasn't here for months and it
was fine because it was the right thing
to do people are going to die this is
the seriously deadly disease since then
the mixed messaging from our government
especially a forest Johnson's go to her
don't go to her stay outside go outside
go on the train if you must go but you
know the trains and then you've got his
right-hand man Dominick coming was just
going on his [__] jollies whenever
you drop the kids off at their
grandparents and take yourself for an
eye test i test place isn't open I'll do
it myself no you got ribs going on
around this area you've got people the
streets are packed in London and then
they finally come out the day and said
oh well from that one you gotta wear
masks on public transport and now I'm
starting now right now that the worst is
over now we gotta wear the mask yeah the
horse is halfway down the field and
you're going come on guys let's get our
boots on the horses and now it's
absolutely fine to protest in the
thousands right this isn't me having a
go at anyone protesting but just to be
clear I'm talking about the complete
lack of leadership and for so many of us
abiding by the rules for months on end
we've done everything what we thought
would be right and now it's like kind of
well just make it up yourselves kind of
out you're on your own you decide
because we don't quite a bit but it's
you're on your own
also this business isn't allowed open
that business isn't allowed open people
are still struggling and suffering on
the basis that people could die so many
people are still being held
- these rules that have been in put in
place we're hearing headlines about oh
you're not allowed to have sex with
someone and it from a different
household it's just ridiculous one and
yet thousands are mixing together in
Trafalgar Square it's become an absolute
false footballers are training together
McDonald's are opening but yet so many
businesses still aren't allowed open I'm
giving up like I'm absolutely giving up
with this absolute [__] anyone who's
still abiding by the rules I respect you
and I think you know everyone's heart
was in the right place for so long
they're all trying to protect people you
know they've hidden so much from us
about you know the ages of the people
who are actually dying from this 88% of
the people according to the UK doctor
website people who died from this or
over the age of 65 they don't want you
to know that for some reason it's not in
any of the headlines it's not in any of
the papers hardly at all because they
don't want you to know that a the
majority of people under 50 are going to
be absolutely fine in our very low risk
eighty eight percent or over 65 that
shows how badly they've also failed the
elderly of this country there is just no
clear messaging and it is just an
absolute shambles and I'm just really
given up on it now like seems pointless
[Applause]
because we judge each other by the I've
got [__] chills he is such a [__]
speaker this guy that's leadership yeah
that's a man who connects with the
people and I'm not saying you know he's
qualified to be the president but when
the president the leader of the country
is so out of touch and you've got a man
in the community like that it really
puts him to [__] shame an old woman I
know and I don't know if this is racism
she's seen the advertisement for the
Michael Jordan documentary the last
dance people raving about you like I
love to ask I love basketball she goes
oh I loved it when he sung that song for
him I didn't correct her because I
didn't want to have to tell her what
happened to our Kelly so I was like yeah
great honey
she seems spacejam once thinks he
produced the whole thing I'm seven
mountain in the skirt no it was I
believe a can flare that was a great
song and it still [__] me up to this
day that our Kelly was
yeah Peter Som that as well yeah as well
he the fourth great song credit do
Michael Jordan I think we should all
know yeah we should or curly yeah and
just Michael Michael Jordan is there
nothing he can't do exactly it's the
remix to ignition [__] out Michael
there's a bang again yeah this is a
classic yeah exactly it's bringing it
back you know Jordan we should do the
remix of the remix with Michael yes
bounce bounce bounce bounce
yes see he was doing a basketball bounce
there you go boom yeah now back to sadly
the reality of being a black man in
modern society you must [__] yourself
when you go on [__] it's only [__]
FBI a when you read those three letters
f.b.eye
Oh in your mind you're going please
everyone's filming it yeah this is
really bad isn't it there's a cop you're
going please be a fake ID I love how
he's like reveling in this moment or
like good for you yeah
so I mean their cards at your card
this guys coming over he's going what am
I supposed it literally looks like David
Brody footballs a copper this guy is
literally thinking have you just
arrested a black FBI agent the irony
here in this situation is that these
Knights not their boss asinus are gonna
get in more trouble than some police
officers who murdered someone normally
if a boss sees you murder the blockades
yes so but like what happened hazy now I
forget difficult because you know one
thing led to another and he's William up
here attention and what it definitely
was yeah yes yeah well there's a body
come on forgot that bit but the rest of
it welcome to the body comp sticky
button sticky up there well there's a
body in there you have forgot to replace
that as well so how long I've been busy
busy how long I'm only monster you not
had your battery in go telly so did
anyone so you do this thankfully no
saving grace isn't it so no one filmed
it no I'm feeling well done yeah yeah
absolutely
probably the Toyota filled up I'm
absolutely knackered so I'll pop off
look at Soho yeah go under the wave yeah
yeah forget all about you do exactly so
more ozone exact and we all make
mistakes you know we're all humans in
this circumstance is humiliate me
everyone sees it you're fired
oh gosh give us your body come back as
well we'll get the fix I know need it
doesn't even work it's not even a real
camera look at this coffee yeah yep
you see two police officers get out of
this car on the side and there's one in
black uniform and you get to run over
yeah oh really yeah for all the
criticized on the cops take this is just
gonna make things worse and worse and
worse
from both sides this needs to like calm
the [__] down like and I can see why the
people are angry at the police but like
doing stuff like that is gonna make them
even worse I think you're not most
astonished by the police have batons how
poorly coordinated an untrained most
just swinging these things
flailing them around that's why I don't
get about it if you're gonna give
someone a weapon train them how to use
it why are you still hitting him what do
you see what I mean look at that there's
no technique yeah it's just swinging
loudly at it the problem is there's more
analysis of the way to athletes play
basketball or football than there is of
this policing we've criticized someone
more for missing an open goal than we
see if in these police people should
care just as much about important [__]
as we do sports absolutely yeah Mounted
Police have been coming down the street
you're gonna see him in the frame now
using flash bangs in front of them and
Mounted Police to clear what has been an
entirely peaceful protest you know what
this is about
Donald Trump wanted to do his speech
wanted to have his little wonder over
with his book your Bible it's not your
Bible it's a Bible he basically was I
clear the streets and the police
probably said will make another
peacefully protest and we call really do
it he was like till I stood up yeah
clear the [__] streets so now all
these people just get bulldoze get the
[__] out the way they're just coming out
swinging now with all the brands jumping
on it you think that people would try
new techniques as to how to deal with
the police turns out the Pepsi didn't
quite nail it they went to going off for
the police a Pepsi you remember when I
think Kendall Kardashian offered the
policeman cousin got chips isn't it
North Kendall really skinny one there's
Kim Kim and then there's the bigger one
who I quite like as well Lamar and the
rest of them are not foster so this is
the most recent clip that we've seen so
this guy was given his helmet back yeah
I don't know if you can see but he's
pouring the blood intake straight away
yeah this is the possible death you know
we're talking did you see his heart yeah
you see his hand were limping they're
just [__] walking posture
look at how many people walk busted
they're not looking at the people as
people anymore they're just looking as
vermin they just look in his just get
these people out the wagon and saying
that he could die his head's pouring of
blood he's clearly smarter or as he
falls you know you know what they said
about that clip oh I'm sorry because the
police officers were
Smith store whatever the [__] they were
given some [__] like if you push
someone over and they smoke their head
on the floor and die like people go down
for that [__] yeah he didn't just trip
and fall ya know
let's go down to the leader of the free
world a man who can finally step in
bring some reason bring some order to
this I hear you I understand let's work
this through all right Donald Trump the
biggest victims of the rioting are
peace-loving citizens in our poorest
communities and as their president I
will fight to keep them safe I will
fight to protect you
I am your president of law and order and
an ally of all peaceful protesters he
says he's an ally of peaceful protesters
we could literally do a compilation of
police brutality just in the last seven
days since he said this even all
Americans were rightly sickened and
revolted by the brutal death of George
Floyd my administration is fully
committed that for George and his family
justice will be served he will not have
died in vain but we cannot allow the
righteous cries and peaceful protestors
to be drowned out by an angry mob he's
missing the elephant in the room here
there's a clear problem within the
American police force of racism he's not
addressing it he's saying all what will
give George Floyd's family just this I'm
basically not the police officer did up
but he's not acknowledging the actual
problem why are people the systemic
problem and by him going our stand with
the peaceful protesters and then sending
the police are with clear instructions
and just look at the actions not the
words to beat the [__] out of any
protesters peaceful or not and get them
away from the streets he's ruling with
an iron fist yeah
America needs creation not destruction
cooperation not contempt security not
anarchy
this is our mission and we will succeed
100% we will succeed our country always
wins
what do you Maine you dumb [__] huh a
country always wins
clear just be clear Donald the people
who you're fighting are also Americans
yes you're losing I mean yeah it's
either way you're punching yourself in
the face first we are ending the riots
and lawlessness that has spread
throughout our country today I have
strongly recommended to every governor
to deploy the National Guard in
sufficient numbers that we dominate the
streets without watching the rest as he
basically says look if the cops don't
saw it I'm bringing in the army this is
the same army the Americans love so much
they're now being threatened with them
so Civil War yeah they'll deal with it a
little - all right guys I'll deal with
it
sort it the laundry well you'll have to
be brave on your armies fighting yeah
because you know what you've lost the
first sentence oh yeah it feels so sorry
for the American people because all of
the things that they love and hold dear
are being turned on the new I feel sorry
for Lawrence chick Paul said nor
whatever I actually do feel a bit sorry
for today no that's the thing kind of
dude Jake Paul one of the biggest
youtubers in the world we've had him on
the podcast a few times it's all kicking
off because he went out during the riots
did a spot of you know kind of watching
the looting yeah watching the looting
and I know he actually did any looting
himself but he was he was in the thick
of it Jake Paul says he and his team did
not participate in looting and vandalism
at an Arizona mall video of the YouTube
star and his team members at the
Scottsdale Fashion Square was posted to
Instagram by Andrew blue so the footage
speaks for itself Jake was out there
videoing the looting and the destruction
of property and this is the thing a lot
of these people who are doing this are
struggling or angry or upset but
struggling mainly and if there's one
thing that Jake Paul isn't struggling
struggling yeah he the guy's a multi
multi-millionaire it wasn't really his
place to go out and do that in my
opinion and also it's this [__]
dangerous dude like stay inside you know
you're one of the lucky people who don't
need to go and do this [__] he [__] up
on that they've charged him with
trespassing which I mean really they say
in the car is like a six-month sentence
if he gets don't worry you know it's
it's bad but he's made a response video
so over the weekend as I'm sure a lot of
you guys probably saw I became the
number one trending topic on
Widow it's not really what you want to
brag about at this point
humble back to start the video we all
love that about Jake it's not hey listen
I need to make an apology here I think I
might have messed I was the bored in the
world all white privilege we've seen
this is the embodiment of it fact that
people still have a mindset to treat
other people differently based on their
skin color is absurd and as someone who
is a believer in change and making
change and someone who wants to take
action I've always tried to use my
platform to raise awareness for things
that I believe in I like Jake I know a
lot people here Jake but like I wouldn't
sit there if someone said what does Jake
use this platform for merely listen
Missy top 10 things fires boxing but I
would pour second Cameron wouldn't be on
the list I'm just saying not being a
[__] doesn't even make top 20 hoop
wouldn't I wanted to use my platform and
film what was going on and what is going
on in our country as we speak to be able
to share and spread the message to the
world and raise awareness that we
shouldn't just be standing there doing
nothing while I completely believe a lot
of what you say there's a part of him
that's also anything is gonna look
[__] cool I am gonna cash in on this
so I don't I don't even then cut I mean
he's not gonna make money off of this
it's just he's a talented video creator
whatever anyone thinks you can disagree
that's fine there's a bit of him that
thinks I want to make something that
other people wouldn't make I wanted to
it's not necessarily as cheap as cashing
in but it is semi your bravery of a
situation where you think I can make
something cool looking out of this
situation to be fair to him a lot of
documentary makers think the exact same
thing but get away with it because what
they make is super tasteful what the
walk versus what Jake makes you know
what I mean but I'm just trying to put
the full picture across I don't use he's
explaining himself as well as he could
have done and this situation to me felt
no different from when I went down to
help with the hurricanes in Houston so
when I went to parkland Florida to be
ground floor with the students there
after they had a horrific school
shooting since I was a kid I've
constantly volunteered for organizations
donated to charitable causes and wanted
to be involved in my community and this
gorge floor tragedy wasn't something
that I could just look past this is an
awkward one because on the one hand not
enough youtubers are using their YouTube
channel platforms to speak about change
being needed a lot of them are putting
the our tweet out but a lot of them
aren't putting it on where the money's
made so credit to Jake for wanting to do
that but on the other hand or his
intention
as snobol that's what he's making them
out to be it's a difficult one we don't
know it's a real [__] honestly and I
know everyone that sees it sitting or
Jay Paul bad guy but it is a difficult
one because he has a history of trying
to do the right thing and in these
situations so this is where it gets
interesting where he is involved in the
looting if not doing the looting himself
he's there as we approach them all I see
one of the most absurd things I've ever
seen in my life hundreds of people
running in and outside of the mall with
bags stealing everything inside of the
mall in hindsight everything's 20/20 and
we shouldn't have been anywhere near
what was going on we should have removed
ourselves from the situation but in the
heat of the moment I wanted to document
what was going on and witnessed it for
myself and at the time my mindset was
that I wanted to document this
experience because I've never seen
anything like it in my life are you
gonna see people smashing windows and
taking [__] I mean it's hardly the first
step on the moon is it no however I
think as a youtuber and someone who
wants to make something this striking
sometimes a film I think actually you
know what maybe I would have followed
maybe I would have gone in and gone
right what am I gonna see here I would
have filmed it better I think in my mind
oh yeah like this is history happening
here I want to go out and see what
people are doing I think that's part of
it yeah clearly and I don't know if
anything will ever happen like this
again in our lifetime yeah I'm just here
documenting I'm not doing nothing while
we're documenting I'm here to document
this I do love the idea of some geezer
sort of running out with like bags of
iPhones oh yeah I'm documenting it too
[__] yeah exactly yeah talking about
the photo of this there are certain
situations and circumstances that I
shouldn't put myself in and I have
learned from this situation and I will
continue to become a better person all
you can do when you make mistakes is a
human is get better from them but don't
let your mistakes define it
I think this apology could have been a
little better no clearer sadly he took
the attention away from where it should
have been because everyone was focusing
on Jake Paul trending number one and not
blacklivesmatter I agree with this tweet
here where he says give me my charges
and let's put the focus back on George
Floyd and black lives matter really good
favorite and I think that the problem is
that Jay Paul has done [__] up [__] in
the past and he has pissed people off
but you know he isn't the evil person
that people may come out to people and I
do think part of the problem right now
with everyone cooped up inside and
everyone feeling frustrated and everyone
feeling angry but when someone does
[__] up like Paul did yeah there's a
major overreaction for me personally
like Twitter
and all of that it's the most toxic it
has ever been in the history of its
creation one wrong move from anyone and
you're just like the devil why I found
interesting about this is the level of
like rejection Logan gets for just
wanting to join in and be a part of this
it's like being against racism is an
exclusive club and that's where people
lose me a bit people see it as trying to
exploit that cause or those kind of
things and you do have to watch out for
people just jumping on the bandwagon to
get a few retweets and stuff but like
it's an angry time where people lash out
I feel like it's a the wrong way to
laugh guy doesn't look like Logan was
actually talking about taking a bit of a
break from social media right before all
this Hubbard I think everything you said
about it's been spot well here is
Logan's actual reply one of my biggest
learnings from all of this and I'm
embarrassed that's taken me 25 years to
realize this it is not enough to be not
racist you have to be anti-racist yes
you condemn those who feign superiority
because of the color of their skin
friends hold friends accountable hold
your family accountable hold yourself
accountable and most importantly we must
hold our authorities accountable logan
goes on to make some very powerful
points yeah a few people have critiqued
this and said you know if he's reading
from a script' and it doesn't feel I
don't know as genuine as what other
people maybe expect from him but also I
would say about that is when you're a
white guy talking about racism there's a
fear that you're gonna put your foot in
it that you're gonna say something wrong
that you're gonna offend people there's
the last thing logan want to do at this
stage especially when he does clearly
care about it if he wants to make a few
[__] not can we cut him some [__]
slack if you're trying to help a
sentiment there should be taken yeah
let's go through some other public
figures who also said things this is
star bender okay air israel artists anya
the UFC middle which i mean of the world
we've been talking for so low we'd
imagine for so long but it's not about
us now so that's all the white people
are people of non different races being
here because we need you we need
[Applause]
he's the most charismatic guy to another
UFC since Konami breath and could be
even more politically powerful use a
stop where who's gonna step up to our
country and say you stand up stand up
with me stand up with me because I got
you you have my word that I'm going to
do everything in my power and then until
my dying day my last breath to do
everything I can to create the change
that is needed to normalize equality
because black lives matter a lot of
people saying the rock could be
President I mean absolutely you wonder
out to be President he could do it in
terms of greats because there is there
is no one better than him really no one
wants to see a presidential acceptance
speech more than me when when he wins it
he goes finally is back in the White
House and everyone's like and then he
turns to the camera the camera zooms in
he does the eyebrow oh my god his
running mate of Malia Obama is in the
background she's doing the eyebrow to us
come back to the White House so before
we get into the video what frustrates me
about YouTube first off and this isn't
me having a Gorch or for any Jews views
are really good you know a million views
many of me as million views and then he
does one about racism 225,000 yeah
what's wrong anything serious anything
for a good cause
this is why we've got a title [__] Jake
Paul in jail so you mugs click it
because this video is one of the best
videos that yours ever done in my
opinion click it's a great video yeah if
we all learn to live together accept
each other give everyone equal
opportunities equal chances then this
world would be so much more of a better
place and it's realized not only on the
victims it relies on all of us not being
worried that if I talk about a sensitive
topic like racism that I might say the
wrong thing so I'll say nothing at all
[__] that or influences that
worried that you may not get to work
with a brand if you talk about racism
mate this is bigger this is far bigger
than any of that [__] one of the few
youtubers who is using their platform to
talk about this and speak about it so
passionately and it's funny because we
critique the video by Joel maybe two
years ago musical company where I was
like this is not the Joella that I know
he can't be yeah and I was a bit
disappointing I was like so [__]
talented this guy can speak he's funny
and you can make music he can do it all
and I didn't feel like he was being the
best him yeah and and that was honest
criticism my problem I you know we've
talked about it since then and I wish
I'd not done it in the way I done it
when I watched that video I was so like
like a father busting with pride I was
like yeah this is that you're well as
good I knew he could be and just so
proud of him you know what I mean that
was just a [__] smashed it now the
YouTube is using this platform yeah Toby
obviously Toby in this video talks about
being very directly affected by racism
because [__] it could be my life next
yeah I understand the problems not as as
big over here in the UK but the problem
exists if I want to go to another
country I'll go do my research and my
which areas are racist which areas to
avoid so now [__] that is you know how
[__] that is it was just good see Toby
talking from the heart I think for quite
a while Toby doesn't really talk like
that
this is this often it has more impact
because he is such like the calm caring
guy who doesn't he's not like someone
new swears all the time so when he's
saying it you're like alright it's kind
of cool yeah he's not in your face yeah
you know he is being serious it's good
that we've got these voices on YouTube
using the platform for the right thing
I'll be honest I thought it'd have been
a lot more for you like were the first
people to make a video out of our circle
of friends about it I was surprised at
just how few did like straightaway don't
get me wrong everyone posted the black
square on Instagram and whatever but
they all did it using your platform
using what people respect you for using
what people know you for using your
moneymaker is the most strong thing you
can do I think part of it isn't that
people don't get also people are a bit
afraid people are a bit scared they're
gonna say the wrong thing especially
white people like like I said earlier
like they're a bit like what if I [__]
it up what if I just draw all this
unwanted attention
like everything is so toxic right now
that you're scared to put a foot wrong
but I still thought that have been a lot
more than what there was what we realize
is as a community a lot of people hadn't
ever really paid this much thought and
just sort of thought the racism thing
but we know I'm not racist so therefore
yeah but the problem is over this last
week people have actually been forced to
think about what they really think and
what a lot of people realize was hold on
a minute I actually don't know much
about this if I say something and [__]
up because I might think something
racist or inadvertently say something I
could [__] my entire career I notice
Jack May made a pause and he said
something along the lines of I'm gonna
take the time to get educated on this
which he isn't exactly what you're
saying as some people just feel like
it's time to learn a bit about not and I
think that's partly why some youtubers
would have held off and this guy drew
brees from New Orleans Saints is a
massive NFL player and admits to the
fact that a majority of his team are
black guys basically still tried to
undermine what Colin Kaepernick did two
years ago three years ago Jordan Colin
Kaepernick was the man who knelt first
during the national anthem predominately
for what we believe was because of
police brutality and he believed that
national anthem for that reason was not
representing the thing that they said it
should represent which was freedom and
bravery and equality and equality yeah
and at the time he was basically told
[__] off [__] off you've done in this
league no one signed him now I remember
they froze him out but what was more
amazing was he was such a great talent
as well
he was audacious and yeah he was very
good so I wasn't let's be clear he
wasn't the best in the league but he
also wasn't the level where you go yeah
you can play so the fact that they got
rid of him was astounding and now he's
been proven right in many regards the
NFL could not be on the worst side of
history here the fact that you froze out
a guy who was saying something that was
felt so right
ridiculous and the coverage of this
story here shows exactly why racism is a
institutional and be still a problem
because the people covering LeBron James
and Colin Kaepernick said shut up you've
got a contract you're just a sports star
the racist people who are in the media
her Drew Brees who said you need to be
quiet you shouldn't be kneeling during
national anthem said finally a sports
star who speaks out and what's the
difference between these two black and
white guys who came out and said that it
was wrong to ever kneel during the
national anthem because he thinks of his
grand
who gave their service to the Army and
the Marines in World War two and that's
why he would never ever kneel during the
national anthem Wow you know I got this
guy when he gave it that explanation I
kinda thought I get it it's a family
thing it means a lot to you right but he
missed the point and to be fair it seems
like he's apologized he has apologized
you see the problem here with the
thinking and I get it jurors apologize
and actually a lot of his teammates have
come in and said yeah we accept your
apology we want to work with you that's
a really positive healthy discourse
since you first try was quite a bar yeah
very much yeah the issue is there were
black people who fought alongside your
Grandad's
there were other people in minority
group that fought alongside your
Grandad's
wasn't just white guys who fought in
wars there's a difference between
ill-informed and a heart of hatred maybe
this guy's ill-informed he had the balls
to apologize and I get that again maybe
this isn't the time where we hold this
guy off in a time when everyone needs to
be honest I'm glad that he was honest
and that is something at least that we
can say is a positive if you can be
honest in the moment and then be honest
in your apology and be honest in
learning you can't ask much more from
someone who might need to change that
was true news we hope that you've
enjoyed it as much as it possibly can
even though it's been a lot of sad
shitty stories hopefully we'll get back
there a little bit funny out next week
but we will still be covering this as
long as we have to because it is it's
the right thing to do hopefully you'll
are alright obviously we do make the
odd-job in here we're not trying to be
insensitive you know it's just our style
if we've hurt or upset anyone that is
what we're trying to do if you're just
mourning for the sake of it don't be a
[__] do you like the video and
subscribe to the true Dada YouTube
channel for more we're back with the
podcast footballs coming back soon live
shows coming back soon more true news
thanks for watching we'll see is Lea